[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonsoir
alors je suis vraiment très très content
d'être avec vous et je suis d'autant
plus content que c'était pas gagné alors
je vais vous raconter un peu mon
histoire je sais que ça fait bien
démarré avec une petite histoire
personnelle ça permet de toucher
émotionnellement mais en plus pour moi
c'est vrai il ya deux ans de ça et
j'étais mourant alors quand je vous dit
mourant on a on a du mal à se figurer
j'avais 33 ans avait trente trois ans
j'avais une tuberculose c'était juste en
train de cracher du sang tout temps
j'avais une pancréatite aiguë pendant
qu'on crée une pancréatite aiguë j'avais
une hépatite c j'étais caché qu tic
c'est à dire que pour 1 m 75 je faisais
30 kg là tu vois je suis pas obèse ni
body builder j'en fais 60 donc tu prends
la même taille mais tu dises en 2d un
fauteuil roulant immunodéprimés et plus
rien qui fonctionne et il ya chez lui un
parcours médical longues très longues et
sur un camp se sent mourir globalement
on cherche des solutions à tout prix
parcours médical classique les hôpitaux
du sud de la france je les connais à peu
près tous par coeur
puis dans la naturopathie et où j'ai
cherché tout azimut un petit peu partout
et puis j'en suis arrivé à un point où
j'étais vraiment un point de non retour
il ya un médecin qui m'a vue qui me dit
la dent dans cinq jours vous vous êtes
mon épouse et moi je comprenais pas
j'avais 33 ans dans la 33 ans c'est le
moment de ta vie où tu as le maximum de
puissance et c'est le moment où tu
commences à te réaliser qu'ils
commencent à fonder une famille
institude et moi j'étais dans un
fauteuil roulant trail de faire pipi
caca dessus en train de cracher du sang
il y avait un sentiment mais
d'impuissance et d'incompréhension qui
était monstrueux membres et pourquoi moi
sérieusement et en plus quand je parlais
à mes parents ils vont raconter mon
histoire d'y et jusqu'à 18 ans 19 ans
est un gamin joie lieu tranquille je te
plutôt le clown de la famille facile
aucun problème pourquoi moi pourquoi moi
pourquoi qu'est ce que j'ai fait
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait pourtant des
comme ça malade est face à nous parle
beaucoup de notre représentation la
plupart du temps de ce qu'on appelle la
maladie fait nous en équipe au sens
comme ça on se balade un et puis là d'un
seul coup au coin d'une rue
un méchant virus une bactérie qui nous
attend et puis l'appui du top dessus
maintenant monsieur monsieur laissez moi
tranquille et hop on attrape une maladie
et j'étais vraiment dans cette
représentation
comment mais pourquoi cette ambition
appuyé une telle accumulation de
sérieusement qu'est ce que j'ai fait au
bon dieu pour avoir tout ça alors
j'étais en train de mourir nous poser
ces questions je me sentais innocent je
je je je partais dans des navets long
questionnement pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'était passé et
j'étais en train de mourir et puis un
matin il s'est passé un truc étrange
mais je pense que ces moments où on est
vraiment aux plus faibles on a des
espèces d'intuition qui monte de
l'intérieur des moments d'un petit peu
de révélations j'ai eu très souvent des
histoires de personnes qui ne visait
qu'à des moments où j'étais très proche
de la mort c'est comme si elle est une
partie de notre confiance qu'il a chier
on est beaucoup plus en en prise avec
quelque chose d'intérieur et là il s'est
passé quelque chose à ce petit matin
espèce de révélations quand je vais vous
le dire ça va paraître très plat je suis
désolé chaque fois que j'ai honte quand
je le dis comme ça mais moi ça m'a
changé la vie et je pense que ça peut
changer vraiment la vôtre aussi
en fait ce qui est monté c'est de me
dire séries cette année là où tu en es
là maintenant là aujourd'hui dans l'état
où tu es en train de te faire pipi caca
dessus dans un fauteuil roulant en train
de cracher du sang est en train de
crever c'est simplement parce que tu as
fait des choix de vie que ses choix de
vie n'étaient pas les bons pas bouger ça
qui monte en moi ouais d'accord bon
c'est une piste mais qu'est ce que je
fais avec ça qu'est-ce que je peux faire
avec ça et vous la faire rapide à la fin
de l'histoire c'est que je suis pas mort
dans sa célèbre de la bce vous donner de
l'espoir que vous ayez envie d'aller au
bout de l'histoire
je suis pas mort et il s'est passé
quelque chose d'étrange parce que ça ça
m'est tombé dessus et je vais vous dire
ça m'est tombé dessus
vraiment comme une commune conviction
savait il peut parfois on rencontre des
gens qui ont du charisme qui parle et
qui on va une de leur conférence
et puis personne tu as bien ils parlent
fort avec avec des phares avec des
arguments avec des expériences et tous
qui l'on repart de la conférence est
c'était fabuleux tu rentres chez toi tu
as ton épouse ou ton mari qui t'attend
c'était bien la conférence ouest est
super c'est là qu'est ce qu'il a dit là
c'était super spéciale
faut il tout mais qu'est ce qu'il a dit
on a adhéré au discours
moi ce que j'ai vécu à ce moment là
c'est pas une adhésion que c'est une
conviction la commission vous savez
c'est quelque chose qui part de
l'intérieur littéralement et qui vous
transforme et chivu ravages
intérieurement
alors fort de cette conviction
ben je me suis dit bon alors c'est mes
choix qu'ils ont fait que je suis dans
l'état où j'en suis bon il va falloir
quand même que je fasse le point sur mes
choix pour essayer de changer les choses
il ya une phrase d'einstein que j'aime
beaucoup qui dit la folie c'est
finalement de faire toujours les mêmes
choses et d'en attendre un résultat
différent si libre il va falloir que je
parte dans une enquête je suis parti
dans une enquête
effectivement j'ai changé des paramètres
dans ma vie et le changement de ces
paramètres qui a priori étaient des
paramètres relativement 27 ans prenez un
je vous parlais de paramètres au niveau
de l'alimentation du rythme de vie de la
relation aux autres
un se dit on le sait tous qu'il faut
relativement bien manger qu'il faut
courir dehors pour s'oxygéner un petit
peu qu'ils font dormir assez on le fait
on le sait tous mais on se dit mais
c'est pas ça qui va faire que tu passes
de la vie à la mort ou de la mort à la
vie
ben si la somme de toutes ces petites
choses
en tout cas pour moi et au travers de
lecteurs ce que j'ai développée après
montré que c'était la somme de ces
petits choix mais qui faisait qu' un
individu à 33 ans pourrait être mourant
et qui pourraient être vivants à 45 ans
j'ai 45 ans alors je me suis lancé dans
une véritable petite enquête et là j'ai
été ébloui par quelque chose je me suis
rendu compte que toute ma vie je l'avais
mener un petit peu un petit peu au
hasard comme vous dit ma mère m'avait
toujours dit il faut que tu marques des
fruits des légumes
oui laporta il faut que tu dormes assez
il faut que tu fasses et de l'exercice
je l'avais entendu mais ça me paraissait
des options ça me paraissait des choses
bon on le faisait on le faisait pas ce
n'est pas si grave que ça au pire ce qui
bougeait pas trop tu étais un peu
grassouillet mais c'était pas grave si
tu manges et mal bon au pire tu avais
quelques petits boutons on m'avait dit
ouais y avait un lien entre les deux
mais ce n'est pas si grave que ça en
fait ce que j'ai découvert c'est que la
vie obéit à des principes ya des grands
principes et ses principes ils ont même
un nom elle s appelle des principes
vitaux
ah ça c'est rigolo parce que s'ils sont
vitaux ça veut dire que ne pas les
respecter ben c'est pas la vie tôt c'est
pas la vitalité alors
ces grands principes je ne les
connaissais pas j'ai joué ma vie au
hasard d'une certaine manière et c'était
tantôt pif canton face et c'est souvent
le sentiment qu'on a quand on parle de
santé et quand j'ai parlé de santé
aujourd'hui j'ai pas prendre le temps de
tout développer mais quand je parle de
santé je parle de santé de l'individu
est pour moi un individu le non dit
exactement ce qu'il devrait nous dire
individu ça veut dire indivisible quand
on parle de santé c'est pas la santé du
corps la santé de l'esprit la santé des
émotions c'est une globalité est
d'ailleurs nombre d'entre nous on pourra
témoigner que quand notre santé physique
se dégrade
il ya souvent aussi notre santé mentale
qui se dégradent les deux vont toujours
de pair eh bien je me suis rendu compte
que ces principes vitaux et bien si on
ne les connaissait pas ont joué la villa
pia fait à pile ou face
c'est à dire que tantôt on faisait des
choix quand on faisait d'autres qui on
parle toujours de choix éclairé mais en
fait nos choix n'était pas du tout
éclairée
alors que si on les connaît on peut
choisir de jouer gagnant
d'ailleurs pour moi c'est la meilleure
définition de la liberté la liberté
c'est connaître les grands principes qui
nous détermine et choisir délibérément
de les respecter la vie c'est les
principes et n'importe quel biologiste
n'importe quelle spécialité sciences
naturelles vous le dira la vis et des
principes l'a dit c'est pas un hasard
l'absence de principes c'est le chaos
alors si vous voulez bien parce que ça
va vous intéresser j'imagine je vais
essayer de vous en parler de
quelques-uns de ses principes à ce que
ces principes qui sont absolument
incroyable et surtout il lui montre à
quel point on ne connaît pas qui nous
sommes
voilà je me balade vous libre j'ai
failli mourir donc maintenant je suis
vivant mais ça veut dire quoi pour vous
être vivant c'est quoi pour vous être
bien est-ce que vous avez conscience de
ce que ça peut représenter
souvent quand je fais des formations je
projette un film là je laissais de faire
une deuxième version je vais vous faire
le film moi même je projette un film et
c'est un film qui m'a interpellé parce
que c'est l'histoire d'une voiture en t
ce qu'il veut aller avec sa voiture en
tc un film qui a été réalisé par john
carpenter dans les années dans les
années 80 à peu près un réalisateur de
films qui peut pas dépôt-vente mai
donc c'est l'histoire d'une voiture
hanté et cette voiture en t elle a été
récupérée par un jeune qui s'appelle
arni et il est fasciné par cette voiture
ya une scène du film où la voiture elle
est complètement cabossé elle est
défoncée et arnie ça fait des jours et
des jours qu'il essaye de la réparer
avec ses propres compétences avec sa
connaissance mais qui lacunaire de la
mécanique c'est pas un mécanicien et là
on est dans on est dans l'atelier de
arnie et là il est il a poussé sur la
voiture qu'il fait bon faire je me fais
en français et en anglais on va faire
traduction simultanée mais écoute me
vieille désolé mais là j'y arrive pas
c'est trop dur pour moi j'ai pas les
compétences je vais pas y arriver
forcément on aurait pu avoir une super
histoire mais je peux pas très pareil
qu'il a il s'en va se retourne et on
entend comme un craquement et on voit le
filtre à air qui était complètement
cabossé qui s'est remis en place
alors là on voir ni la scène elle est
super band le film s'appelle christine
en voir nicki ce recul comme ça il se
met face à la voiture il la regarde et
il fais ok schumi bon en français c'est
moins sexy et ça fait ok montre moi en
anglais ça peut-être et là on voit la
voiture se reconstruire sous nos yeux
bon ces effets spéciaux des années 80
donc si laborieux c'est un peu comme
quand tu vois star wars preuve les
premiers épisodes tu délires ou s'il ya
eu il ya eu déjà eu de l'évolution
depuis il n'empêche que la voiture se
reconstruit et vous savez ce qu'il ya de
fantastique dans ce film qu'est ce qui
en fait un film entre guillemets
d'horreur mais c'est simplement qu'on a
donné à quelque chose qui n'est pas
vivant une voiture la capacité du vivant
parce que moi j'ai essayé
j'habite en montagne et en fait les
routes sont très étroites et
ma femme a beau nier le cantique bosch
de la volvo tout habillé tout annuel qui
a été déchiré
donc moi j'ai vu le film et christine
j'ai posé la voiture sur une place de
parking tranquillement au repos j'ai
fêteront pas de côté je regardais bas
volvo qui est ok
montre-moi allait se passe me dis je le
dire en suédois peut-être comprend pas
le français
je les fais au suédois je m'en souviens
plus exactement ce qui s'est passé ben
ouais parce que le premier principe que
j'ai découvert c'est que le vivant est
par nature aux torts et par an par
nature le vivant s'adapte en permanence
à son environnement
mais ça tu vois on te le dis comme ça
n'importe quel biologique va te dire la
nature même du vivant c'est d'être auto
réparant tu te coupe tu te fais une
plaie appelés hev à cicatriser il ya
tout un processus extrêmement complexe
qui passe par une multitude d'étapes
qu'elle pourrait faire une conférence
pendant cinq heures sur la cicatrisation
tellement c'est fabuleux ce qui se passe
à cette échelle là on le sait tous on se
compte et ça serait pas on le sait tous
mais ce qu'on en prend la mesure
t'imagines quantité jeunes si chaque
fois que tu avais eu une maladie chaque
fois que tu avais un problème dans ton
corps ta mère tu avais dit ok tu es
vivant et parce que tu es vivant mais la
fonction normale de ton corps c'est
d'aller vers l'auto réparation et si
actuellement on ne constate pas une auto
réparation c'est qu'il ya des entraves
et ses entraves tous les deux si tu veux
on va partir dans une enquête et on va
essayer de les découvrir
quand je vous parle de la révélation que
j'ai eu c'est exactement ça ça a d'abord
commencé par une enquête qu'est ce qui
dans mon mode de vie empêche mais que ma
puissance vitale qui à l'intérieur
puisse exprimer de la manière qu'elle
devrait s'exprimer puisque je suis
vivant et puisque claude bernard par
exemple avec le principe de
l'homéostasie me dis parce que tu es
vivante encore et autorise par an et
ouais mais je le vois pas ça se fait
comment pourquoi je le vois pas ben on
va faire une enquête et soit c'est comme
ça que je leur présente c'est un peu
comme si face à toi tu avais une table
de mixage toi il ya des des
potentiomètres sur la table de mixage et
puis tu prends ça allait regarder lui ok
côté alimentation eau les biens rythme
de vie ou la balance niveau du sommeil
non il faudrait leur amener un petit peu
relation avec anne en relation avec les
autres c'est clair franchement je passe
du temps beaucoup trop isolés et où je
le remets à la norme
c'est en règle un petit peu tousser
potentiomètre est ce que nous dit le
vivant c'est à partir au moment où les
potentiomètres respecte les besoins
vitaux de l'individu alors à ce moment
là cette puissance inouïe qui est à
l'intérieur de nous mais elle peut agir
et le vivant et aux torts et par an non
parce que je voulais pas dit mais la
tuberculose la pancréatite l'hépatite c
si de suite je ne les ai pas traités en
tant que tel je ne suis pas allé
chercher des substances exogènes
qu'elles soient naturelles ou pas
naturel pour les réparer j'ai simplement
fait en sorte de réunir les conditions
pour que la puissance vitale qui avait à
l'intérieur de moi puis se révéler
dernière puissance vitale puissance
vitale
ça ça fait un peu quand même mais on
parlait de la guerre des étoiles ça fait
un peu le retour du jedi lattois
puissance vitale john nom mais qui sont
vitales je te parle et parle d'un autre
principe que j'ai découvert au cours de
ma petite aventure truc fabuleux qui
s'appelle l'autophagie là qu'ils ont
entendu parler d'autophagie quand même
quelques dents allez vous mettez pas
l'autophagie m'apporte ans a valu le
prix nobel en 2016 en japonais voit pas
vous prononcer son nom âge et je le peux
ap ça lui a valu un prix nobel il a
montré que le blocage des processus
d'autophagie qu dans le corps expliquer
l'émergence et l'explosion actuelle dé
troubles neurodégénératifs comme maladie
de parkinson et alzheimer
qu'est ce que c'est que l'autophagie
toutefois si son truc fabuleux ça te dit
que quand simplement tu t'arrêtes de
manger et bien en ce moment là il ya un
mécanisme qui se met en place dans le
port dans lequel le corps va penser à
ceux consommés lui-même mais là on a du
bol c'est qui se consomme pas au hasard
tu imagines tu sentant repas biche tu
perds un oeil au bas mot estime l'auteur
noah était super flippant
je crois qu'on a tous la croyance qu'on
va perdre un oeil parce qu'on n'arrête
pas de bouffer tout le temps on mange
tout leur passage des piétons non
attends je vais pas sauter au repas j'ai
pas envie de parler de moi paul tracy
autophagie qu'il est quand même beaucoup
plus intelligent que ça il nous dit que
mais quand canton quand on met le corps
au repos au niveau digestif
en fait on a l'impression que quand on
s'arrête de manger on s'arrête de manger
on s'arrête pas manger jamais simplement
corps au lieu de recevoir de la
nourriture de l'extérieur comment le
corps commence à prendre sa nourriture
de l'inter
et qu'est ce qui va venir chercher il va
venir chercher ce qu'il ya de plus vicié
détériorer en nous il va commencer à re
sic les tous les déchets cellulaire
toutes les vieilles cellules qui
traînait dans un coin c'est celle qu'on
avait balancé avec le ballet sous
l'armoire pour pas le voir là pendant
qu'on faisait le ménage crois qu'il va
les prendre il commence à lui nettoyer
et il a montré mais peu les troubles
neurodégénératifs actuellement contre
lesquelles on se bat pour lesquels on
dépense des millions et des millions
étaient essentiellement liée au défaut
de processus autophagie a maintenant
moins dans ma petite tête de catalan je
me dis mes défauts le processus
d'autophagie que ça veut simplement dire
qu'on n'a pas de période dans notre
journée ou dans notre année dans lequel
on est effectivement au repos digestif
si je vais essayer de vous montrer aussi
là dedans c'est que l'interrupteur qui
peut déclencher l'autophagie c'est nous
qui l'avons c'est une décision je vous
parlais d'un autre principe aussi que
j'ai découvert c'est le principe du
repos à ça le principe du repos je laime
beaucoup parce que moi généralement
quand j'allais me coucher le soir
j'allais dire j'allais me reposer
j'espère qu'après cette conférence plus
jamais vous pourrez dire que vous allez
vous reposer parce qu'à l'échelle du
vivant le repos n'existe jamais n'a pas
ce que tu imagines là aussi tu vas tu
allongé qui va te reposer et où s'arrête
le coeur s'arrête les poumons s'arrête
la d6 arrête la circulation s'arrête on
est mal barré
plus personne ne voudront bien je
comprends les enfants qui veulent pas
aller se coucher le repos n'existe pas à
l'échelle des villes en europe on
n'existe pas on a simplement deux modes
de fonctionnement un mode de
fonctionnement dans lequel notre énergie
à les diriger vers l'extérieur on est en
interrelation avec notre environnement
et un mode dans lequel ben évidemment on
est beaucoup plus en détente et dans
lequel l'énergie est investi à
l'intérieur et est investi à l'intérieur
pour faire quoi
mais les fameux processus de
régénération de restructuration de
réparation dont je vous ai parlé et
alors au cours de mon aventure
non parce que c'est une aventure qui a
pris quand même pas mal d'années qui
s'est basé aussi sur énormément de
recherches scientifiques
j'ai rencontré un quatrième élément sur
lequel j'avais envie de vous faire
réfléchir aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
appelait le symptôme ont laissé tous les
symptômes de la fièvre va des boutons à
une maladie elle tuberculose tu as une
pancréatite pas autant de alors j'allais
déjà utilisé le mot autant de
manifestations
et dans ce que j'ai découvert qui va
être je vais tels que je voulais vous
présenter c'est un système de croyances
lorsque j'ai découvert est bien le
symptôme n'est qu'un signal le cndd
c'est un signal pas de la fiev c'est un
signal pas des boutons c'est un signal
c'est une manifestation qui se passe à
l'échelle du port et nous on a toujours
l'impression que c'est un problème c'est
à dire que l'idée dans lequel on évolue
principalement sais tu as des symptômes
la suppression de ces symptômes équivaut
à la résolution du problème dans le
modèle que j'ai découvert dans les
principes que j'ai découvert bien le
symptôme n'est rien d'autre qu'une
manifestation
et comme disait hippocrate père de la
médecine en toute chose cherche la cause
et quand tu as trouvé la cause cherche
la cause de la cause jusqu'à revenir à
la cause première
le symptôme c'est un signal absolue dans
volvo j'aime beaucoup ma voiture je suis
passé du temps dans ma voiture donc une
grosse affinité pour ma volvo je suis
pourtant en fit sa première fois de ma
vie où j'ai une vraie voiture de
monsieur à 40 50 et l'ama volvo il ya un
truc ses mains quand on ne met pas la
ceinture sabip et j'ai tendance j'ai
gardé un petit côté punk de mes 20 ans
une fois je me suis dit bon elle minerve
cette bagnole qui est toujours fermée de
ma ceinture je vais tenir
donc je commence à rouler beep beep beep
beep m'en fous je me dis elle va craquer
au bout d autres viettel a craqué 30
secondes après bbb paiement fondement
fou à 6 minutes j'ai craqué monsieur dit
les suédois sont plus pervers que les
catalans j'ai mis ma ceinture avec les
symptômes c'est exactement dans
l'histoire de vie des symptômes il y en
a eu des signaux il y en a eu à 20 ans
petit signal à 25 ans à 30 ans
et à 33 ans les derniers symptômes qui
vont obliger à bouger qui m'ont obligé
vraiment me remettre en cause qui ont
obligé vraiment à ce que je remette en
cause tout mon système de croyances par
rapport à la capacité de mon corps et à
la responsabilité dans mes choix de vie
mais c'était que j'étais moi alors j'ai
tendance de parler d'un système vraiment
de croyance dans lequel nous sommes
on a tous évolué dans un système de
croyance et le problème c'est que
parfois quand on est né dans un système
de croyances on a l'impression que c'est
la réalité parce que c'est tellement
présents autour de nous on a
l'impression que c'est la réalité la
réalité on croit que par exemple
mais quand y'a un symptôme qui apparaît
de ce symptôme le supprimer équivaut à
guérir la cause à revenir à la base
alors je parle de système de croyance
est ce que rien ne démarre en dehors de
nos systèmes de croyance c'est parce que
j'ai cru que quelque chose d'autre était
possible parce que j'ai eu la conviction
que quelque chose d'autre été possible
parce que j'ai eu la conviction que mon
corps avait la capacité de se réparer
alors que tout les signes ont indiqué
qu'il était mourant que j'ai pu mettre
en place des choses qui m'ont permis
ensuite d'atteindre mon objectif
alors j'ai créé une école je suis tout
seul pour l'instant dans mon école
mais c'est une façon de la deûle à nous
mais d'une certaine manière j'ai appelé
ça l'école du port intelligent l'école
du port intelligente elle se base sur
tous ses principes
je pourrais vous en parler d'eux et
normandeau tellement le vivant est
fascinant mais l'école du port
intelligente elle elle se base sur des
principes est elle une chose elle nous
dit nous sommes à l'image de notre
environnement
l'humain il pas l'image de son
environnement et il est responsable de
ses choix qui vont induire sa qualité de
vie alors l'école du pont intelligente
elle a un inconvénient par rapport à
l'autre école
l'autre école vu que moi j'ai la mienne
je l'appelais l'épaule du port
intelligents les autres j'ai appelé ça
l'école du bourg con je me suis
distribuer le bon reliefs désolés assez
dur comme ça on veut toujours être le
bon dans le trait dans l'école du corps
qu'on sait pas mal il ya un truc qui est
vraiment confortable c'est que tu es
innocent est à des maladies qui te tombe
dessus toute ta vie tu toi tu sais pas
trop pourquoi
c'est une tranquille tu étais thénard tu
vois qu'un seul robin qui un truc qui te
tombe dessus
alors avantage de l'école du corps qu'on
sait que tu es innocent qui est pour
rien par contre gros inconvénient
qui est innocent et qui pour rien mais
les comprendre qu'il veuille aller n'y a
pas de vivre parce que dans l'école du
pont intelligent il ya une chose qu'il
faut prendre et qui est lourd à prendre
des parts c'est la responsabilité
responsabilité ne veut pas dire
culpabilité c'est que deux choses
complètement différentes parce que la
plupart du temps nos choix nous les
faisons sans savoir
nous les faisons par défaut d'une
certaine manière parce qu on n'a pas
imaginé faire autre chose dans l'école
du port intelligent on reprend toutes
leurs responsabilités ont dit des
conditions qui sont les nôtres
actuellement elles sont le fruit d'un
choix d'un choix parfois qu'on a fait
sans trop vouloir le faire mais elles
sont quand même le fruit d'un choix et
l' avantage c'est que parce qu'elles
sont le fruit d'un choix
alors on récupère quelque chose
d'extraordinaire c'est la capacité à
agir
la puissance on la récupère en acceptant
la responsabilité alors au travers de ma
vie au travers de ce chemin
tu aurais pu me laisser mort et qui
finalement va mener maintenant
aujourd'hui à 45 ans à être d'une
vitalité d'une santé que je n'ai même
pas connu alors que j'avais 20 ans mais
j'ai découvert quelque chose de fabuleux
c'est cette puissance qui siège à
l'intérieur de moi et cette puissance
elle demande qu'une seule chose que je
prenne ma responsabilité que je la
connais ce que je connaisse les
principes qui permettent sa libération
et que je les respecte délibérément
c'est ce que j'ai appelé la liberté et
c'est que j'appelle aussi la santé je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]